non vous savez qu'on ne bouge pas
parking on est moche pas en aluminium
la bouger bouger
soit je vois que c'est oui j'essaie
catherine mais je crois que c'est le
prénom je crois qu'on n'y peut rien si
tu veux c'est un truc de laurent vité
jamais fait alors en faire l'anti
portrait chinois d'accord alors par
exemple donc de vous dire si vous étiez
une fleur ou un pendriez un mieux aux
autistes c'est un peu ridicule
je vais vous dire si vous étiez un
défaut un des shows wii ou la vache un
défaut j'hésite entre mais jouer votre
groupe
pensez vous qu'ils étaient une injure
une injure wattez jour on croirait que
nordiste une magie une maladie l'amour à
un accident un accident les crottes de
mon chien
j'ai un chien depuis vigion riches ils
auraient alors il s'appelle chocolat
c'est ça non pas chocolat il est chaud
chocolat il s'appelle rebelles avant
euros comme son père ah c'est pas moi
qui ai un rosaire si vous étiez une
perversion
si j'étais une conversion le ferait
votre questionnaire chertier rire de la
bonne réponse une guerre une guerre
la prochaine ouais un vice un vice le
sexe laurent et qu'on lui dit sexy qu'on
salisse non obligatoire non trahison
trahison il trahison de celle qui m'a le
plus marqué ces dernières années c'est
celle de nicolas sarkozy et d'edouard
balladur
voilà mais voilà oui effectivement ils
sont une arme si j'étais une arme je
serai humour un supplice un supplice
crémant sarno
sans compter bien les actifs jugés non
michel j'exagère panne mardi soir mais
il ya tous les samedis maintenant elle
est derrière jeudi une cicatrice une
cicatrice l'arrêt du cul c'est après si
vous étiez un poison le tabac une [ __ ]
linda la connecta croiser ici y croiser
ces croisés en affaires labrador à
l'impôt un impôt sur les grandes
fortunes
moi je suis pour oui moi je me suis
jamais plaint de payer des sommes
exactement dans les gens qui gagnent de
l'argent à deux reprises toute chasse et
la cox une panne sexuelle
oui c'est la plus en perdant jamais
l'emmener à votre à jamais mais je suis
tombé dans la marmite du viagra quand
j'étais petit que le viagra c'est une
petite pilule bleue comme et quand comme
sous la langue
exact l'acfo la m c'est des mecs ils bon
signe et hier j'ai testé pour
l'événement du jeudi elle est parue à
l'événement du jeudi c'était le nom du
journal de l'île car vous avez testé le
viagra par bruno masure jambière gauche
et laurent habib pied bon voilà c'est à
dire ça vous fait rire c'est bien sûr
pas comme moi vous avez
si vous étiez une torture une torture
clémence ah non moi si vous étiez une
humiliation une nuit dans le bide
ah ouais le bide n'y a rien de pire vous
êtes sur scène ou même à la radio ou à
la télé vous croyez dire un truc drôle
et c'est quand la et rigole pas voilà ça
c'est une humiliation
1 ça vous arrive jamais si ça arrive je
la vois tout le monde avant si vous
étiez mort la petite mort voilà le pied
janvier 2000 et janvier 2000 en sais pas
si tu as rappelle misrahi un essai chez
plon voilà merci bien alors avant de
recevoir notre invité suivant